"y" es igual a un octavo de "x" cúbica
menos "x" cuadrada.
¿Sobre qué intervalo la función "y"de "x"
tiene una razón de cambio promedio de un medio?
Así que vayamos intervalo a intervalo,
calculando la razón de cambio promedio,
así que primero pensemos en el intervalo que está aquí,
donde "x" está entre -2 y 2...
-2,
es menor
que "x"
que es menor
que 2.
Así que pensemos,
¿cuál es el valor de la función, cuándo "x" es igual a -2?
Entonces "y"valuado en -2 es igual a un octavo
por -2 al cubo
menos -2 al cuadrado,
lo que es igual a,
vamos a ver...
-2 al cubo es 8 negativo,
-8 entre 8 es -1,
-2 al cuadrado es 4 positivo,
pero luego vas a tener que restar eso,
entonces es -4 y esto es igual a -5.
Y "y"valuada en 2...
"y"valuada en 2,
es igual a un octavo
por 2 al cubo
menos 2 al cuadrado...
menos 2 al cuadrado.
Eso va a ser igual a un octavo por 8 es 1,
y -2 al cuadrado es -4,
que es igual a -3.
Entonces si quieres encontrar
tu razón de cambio promedio,
tienes que averiguar
cuánto está cambiando el valor de tu función
y dividirla entre cuánto ha cambiado tu "x".
Así que podemos hacer una tabla aquí...
podemos hacer una tabla aquí...
"x" y "y".
Cuándo "x" es -2,
entonces "y" es -5,
cuándo "x" es 2 positivo
"y"es -3.
Entonces,
¿cuánto cambio "y"?
"y"incrementó...
"y" incrementó en 2...
"y" incrementó en 2
y "x" incrementó...
"x" incremento en 4,
y puedes obtener estos valores,
puedes simplemente verlos,
"y" incrementa de este punto a este punto y
"x" incrementa de este punto a este punto
o puedes decir -3 menos 5 negativo es 2 positivo,
esa es la diferencia entre -3 y -5.
Si decimos, 2 menos 2 negativo,
esto te da, una vez más,
la distancia o la diferencia, te va a dar 4,
pero si ves esto, está claro que
mientras "x" se incremente a 4
"y" incrementa en 2.
Entonces, nuestra razón de cambio promedio
sobre este intervalo va a ser...
nuestra razón
de
cambio
promedio
de
"y"
con respecto a "x"...
con
respecto
a "x",
va a ser igual a...
mientras que "x" cambia en 4,
en 4 positivo,
"y" cambia en 2 positivo, lo que es igual a un medio.
Así que parece ser que la razón de cambio promedio
sobre este intervalo justo aquí...
sobre este intervalo justo aquí es un medio.
Por lo que tuvimos suerte esta vez, nuestra
primera opción y esto de opción múltiple,
por lo que no tenemos que seleccionar más de una aquí,
la primera cumplió con nuestro criterio,
por lo que sabemos que es la respuesta.
Pero déjame hacer otra de estas opciones,
para mostrar porque no es la respuesta.
Entonces encontremos la razón de cambio promedio,
entre este punto y este punto.
Entonces, hay que hacerlo.
Hagámoslo en otro color...
lo haremos en
morado...
Así que 0 es menor que "x"
que es menor que 4,
solo haré una tabla aquí...
"x" y "y"...
Entonces cuando "x" es 0,
¿cuánto es "y"?
"y"va a ser un octavo por 0 menos 0,
"y" va a ser 0.
Cuando "x" es 4,
¿cuánto es "y"?
"y" va a ser...
mmm... vamos a ver,
un octavo...
trataré de calcularlo mentalmente...
un octavo por 4 al cubo...
4 al cubo es...
64...
un octavo por 64 es 8...
va a ser 8 menos 4 al cuadrado que es 16,
8 menos 16 es
-8... ehhh... -8.
Entonces, en ésta, cuando tenemos
que "x" se está incrementando en 4,
"x" se incrementa en 4
¿qué pasa con "y"?
"y" ha disminuido en 8,
por lo que la razón de cambio promedio
de "y" con respecto a "x" aquí es...
"y" cambia... puedo escribir...
mi cambio en "y"...
esta letra griega delta
es el símbolo para el cambio...
el cambio en "y" es
-8,
mientras que mi cambio en "x"
es 4.
Por lo que la razón de cambio
promedio aquí es,
-2.
Es negativo porque mientras que
"x" se incrementa, "y" diminuye.
Y para cada... en promedio...
para cada incremento en "x", "y"disminuye en 2,
por eso obtuvimos ese -2 aquí.
Así que claramente, la razón de cambio promedio
de este no es un medio
y esto confirma que ésta, no es la respuesta.
Y sabemos también...
y los invito a que las prueben también,
que estas les van a dar una razón de cambio
diferente a un medio positivo.